[Musik]
ein film wo unter tut gott wo bedruckt
opfer wo er begegnet mit der methode vor
der restaurative justiz scharf arysta
auto in lenzburg der
justizvollzugsanstalt wie gut das
konkret in der city wie stets scharfe
micro für dialog das möglich die
lektorin direkte dialog zur show und der
unterstützungs person und angehörigen
stattfinden sollte es gewünscht ist und
dem ich wirklich das ist es gibt für das
und drei landen einige anwender darüber
was sie im nachhinein außen herum das
tat rück konsequent zu erkennen von
einzeltaten auf der bio linien wachs
spielpause verdoppelt und das leere
verantwortlicher benannt auckland partie
entwickelt und da gibt es natürlich die
direkte gespräche zwischen den taten war
das möglich ist und das gewünscht ist
und haben auch angehörige unterstützt
person heute bis sie geht aber mit dem
führungsteam die aktiven briefe oder
video korrespondenz mit dem mit was ist
bedürfnis produkte also beide sind
involviert opfer und täter ich habe mich
mit einem film einfach fordert der
mutter mörder von der eigenen tochter
verdient ich finde es einfach unmöglich
ist wirklich wenig zu oft ist es möglich
ein wunsch im winter nicht weit davon
ausgenommen
die toxische
energie ihnen inneren auszahlte das
ganze hätte und das ist das oft angst
ich das ganze thema abschließen ganze
und vergabe sowie ein schlussstrich ist
also ein prozess verstanden ist richtig
beim herkömmlichen stoffbezügen der
importe und was jetzt als opfer so
zeigen wir neue rolle übernommen
also mich sehr darauf richten aber die
eigene kultur des sehr stark toxisch top
5 sekunden gesehen durch platzeck heute
geschichte und mir gesagt das wird doch
nicht offiziell geschlossen vorkommen in
gerichtsprozessen das so und dass mir
nie wieder platz gibt es stimmen muss
ich jede geschichte lieferte das ganze
vorbei wo man weiß es aber schon mal
bewältigung sehr wichtig ist relativ
wieder herstellen was wird denn wieder
hergestellt es geht um eine mischform
operierte steril aber wieder hat steht
dass jan tore bekommen auch die fragen
wahnsinnig lage und war meistens einmal
danken taten zu verantworten dass sie
mit dem was ich sehe und er warf in
jedem fall die zukunft gibt es beim
vielfältiger das tor machen wie sie am
anfang wirklich ganz am startpunkt vor
der startelf steht mit jeder hilft sehr
kurzer druck führt wenn wir in denen
opel und die vorbereitung von direktor
opfer die alle wo im moment im laufen
sie amerika das interesse von seiten
gewachsen ist und dass man das die
elektrotechnologie und sedimente machen
also sehr positiv gibt es auch unter
jährige wissenschaftliche wo das stütze
ja sie in interviews erneut kritisch als
die vier stangen mehr westliche welt
gesetzt und das ist sehr für studien
gemacht worden sechs trotz wiederholter
zur effektivität und studie sehr
einheitlich das übrigens prozent von den
versicherten sie 30 räder und wird das
operationsfeld wieder machen
datensicherheit
ich habe alles liebe das gebot du sollst
deine feinde lieben im neuen testament
duncan hat ihre strategie justiz auch
religiöse hintergründe
als ich effektiv ist oft direkt am tv
tisch und müsse der mensch der kulturen
und religionen vor fängt warte warum es
als grundwerte der stative zwingt zum
beispiel für gelungene religionen und
von 1 ist hätte bindendes element und
das ist natürlich nicht auf jedes kind
kann das nicht nötig sie war so genau
und wie ist das duett abgeordneter bin
also warum glaubt monika also ich sehe
das dorf al midan kanada wo zwei jungs
ich sehe wo wahnsinnig randalierte das
ist erstmal ob sie aber jede nacht ist
absolute betriebe selbst schaden
angerichtet grundstück und das ist nicht
einfach es ist ein bisschen riis und das
ist aber nicht versuchen das zu sagen
was sie weiß
frage was wir steinen stangen nicht was
man sich sicherlich sollte war es nicht
und wir dass sie wenigstens ein gewisser
schaut wieder gutmachen damals die
reparaturen machen und sehr schwierigen
natürlich nicht fehlen
und der ist nicht ganz falsch auch wenn
hier eigentlich okay
und das ist wirklich mit einer zweiten
ergangen sich mit dem glöckchen hingeht
und gestand ich mir sogar vorstellen
möchte die zwei randalierer lakers bitte
sagen wie es mir schon wieder figur
machen und durch ackerbau aber die
menschen die zweitgrößte was für ein
schwachsinn das ihk de verantwortlich
und ganzen hat es mich nicht unterstützt
hätte schwere situationen und so gut die
auswirkungen auf eine seite
das richte das nachher auf genaue
haltung vertritt hat und islamische
projekten stange oder sehr schnell auf
die usa und ferrari vorne landet
natürlich hoffen die europäische länder
betrachtet das spiel vorbei
konfrontation an was fasziniert sie
persönlich sind so richtig drin
das ist es funktioniert also ins auge
roxy und empfang ist schaffen und gerade
gespräche mit der firma sie auf die
themen frauen mit übergewicht habe ich
das für möglich dass rational peter und
in einem stativ justiz studierte und
gemerkt was das eigentliche es war eine
kennt und es funktioniert nicht wenn das
so gut funktioniert und ist immer gut
und ich wüsste was ist wenn es
professionelle und natürlich den opfer
unter trümmern schaffen die so genannten
tarife gilt also als andere betroffen
herzlichen dank für den blick vor ist
kein klingt ja und da gerade jetzt
wieder mit der sternstunde philosophie
und kollektiv post trifft einer vor der
bedeutendste intellektueller unserer
zieht der amerikanische soziologe
richard sennett
[Musik]